I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
that's right Ariel we're starting right
now does anyone else get chills when
Hallie Bailey belts it out in these
trailers I mean that girl can sing and
if you've been hiding under a rock you
may not know that Disney's live-action
The Little Mermaid is almost here and if
you were a child of the 80s and 90s or
just someone who was super into musicals
then you're definitely going to want to
catch this one in theaters here's
everything you need to know about the
live action The Little Mermaid
[Music]
okay so here is what we're gonna break
down
let's dive in something about you seems
different I can't quite figure it out
she got legs you idiot so you may not
have known but Disney is not the
originator of The Little Mermaid is that
even possible in fact this story comes
all the way from Denmark in 1837 from
master fairy tale writer Hans Christian
Anderson who wrote about an unnamed
mermaid who desperately wants an eternal
soul and this OG version is actually
much darker than what we grew up
watching like when she walks on her new
leg she actually feels stabby knife
pains and the prince marries someone
else and so she dies and then becomes
seafoam you know real kid-friendly stuff
but honestly you really gotta read it
for yourself because it doesn't end
there and the message is actually quite
beautiful something the 1989 version
definitely lacked but good news we hear
that the live-action remake has actually
focused on a more profound message as
well just kind of hoping that it's not
going to be as dark as Anderson but
enough of dark Danish folklore let's
move on to some lighter thingamabobs and
that I see
and as I see
so Disney's first foray Into The Little
Mermaid actually started with the
release of the animated version in 1989
and it became a critical and Commercial
hit that kick-started the Disney
Renaissance all this to say this was
that magical time period in the 90s when
they released hit after hit and we have
Ariel and Company to think for starting
it all the animated film was so
successful that it had two follow-up
films two thousands a little mermaid two
Return of the Sea and the Little Mermaid
Aerials beginning in 2008 but both were
kind of met and went direct to video so
we'll brush over those for time's sake
the solution to your problem is simple
yeah
as we've seen in recent years Disney's
been revamping those Renaissance films
as live action remakes and it wasn't
until 2016 that they announced it was
The Little Mermaid's turn and from the
looks of it the CGI probably took a
while but the wait is over now and we
have High Hopes so what can we expect in
terms of similarities and differences
between both versions
yeah I got an aesthetically please using
configuration of hair it sounds like the
core plot will be the same but we know
director Rob Marshall is reimagining
will have some important Modern Day
updates and for those of you who don't
know Rob Marshall has directed some of
your favorites like Chicago Mary Poppins
returns into the woods Pirates of the
Caribbean on trains or tides and Memoirs
of a Geisha whatarezzy I think it's a
true love
let's get back to those modern updates
star Holly Bailey said that it's
actually Ariel's desires that have
changed from the original she said quote
I'm really excited for my version of the
film because we've definitely changed
that perspective of just her wanting to
leave the ocean for a boy and she
mentioned that it's more about Ariel
finding freedom for herself because of
the world that she's obsessed with and
that Prince Eric is the cherry on top
but it's not gonna be all about him and
I'm just gonna throw this out there
Prince Eric is not a bad Cherry to have
on top I mean another difference is that
Rob Marshall gave Eric more personality
because as we all know he kind of was
the weakest character in the original He
also mentioned that Eric will have a
similar trajectory as Ariel as they both
feel like they don't fit in their
respective worlds and work together to
break down the barriers that surround
their lives oh my God if Eric becomes a
mermaid I will die whatever happens it
kind of seems like we're gonna get a
more modern and sophisticated version of
this beloved tale and we can get behind
that
also expect to see slight changes made
to two of the original songs Sebastian
the Krabs Kiss the Girl and Ursula's
main villainous number Poor Unfortunate
Souls God I love that song now kiss the
girl will understandably be updated to
add themes of consent but it's actually
Poor Unfortunate Souls supposed changes
that are bothering fans so the lines
that will be updated are the men out
there don't like a lot of blabber they
think a girl who gossips is a poor gets
on land it's much preferred for ladies
not to say a word and it's she who holds
her tunnel gets a man the reason fans
are criticizing changes to Ursula's song
is because they're saying she's a
villain and villains say mean and
manipulative things to get what they
want and Ursula wants Ariel's voice so
it kind of makes sense that she would
say those things right either way it's
nice to know that we're moving away from
the old school boy obsessed themes of
the old and bringing in a more
well-rounded approach to the women in
this new film and now that we're talking
music another similarity between both
films is that Alan Menken has returned
as composer for the live action remake
The Little Mermaid was the first film I
ever scored it's especially emotional
coming back wait so The Little Mermaid
was his first and he won the Oscar for
best original score and he was also
nominated twice alongside Howard Ashman
for best original song for both kiss to
girl and Under the Sea and won the Oscar
for the latter if you guys don't know
who Alan Menken is this man basically
created the soundtrack to our childhood
we may or may not need to freeze his
brain this man also went on to score
other Disney Renaissance favorites like
Beauty and the Beast Aladdin and
Pocahontas which just kept the Oscars
rolling in I mean the man is a beast
question now is will he start racking up
more rewards with the revamp score in
this remake we're gonna have to wait and
see but his chances are high because
joining the genius is another beloved
musical genius lin-manuel Miranda that's
right Alan and Lynn have joined forces
for the good of all our ears and here's
a bit of a sneak peek behind the curtain
on their experience and with lin-manuel
Miranda who is so brilliant the songs
we've written expand what little mermaid
is I feel really proud to work on The
Little Mermaid because these characters
live in my heart they live in our hearts
too Lynn and it really was a music all
those years ago that solidified this
story and these characters in our hearts
okay so speaking of characters who's
playing who
I really didn't expect to find her here
the king can never hear it look at that
you got it got it
sorry what'd you say again I'm a dead
crab let's start with the main character
Ariel played by Halle Bailey so she's
best known for being one half of the
musical Duo Chloe and Hallie with you
guess it her sister Chloe Bailey and
here's a clip from our interview where
she tells us what it was like getting
the part it's a really a dream come true
Rob Marshall is the best when he called
me I didn't believe it
he was like Ariel this is how he told me
because of course when I answered the
phone he goes is this Ariel am I
speaking to Ariel and I'm like what so
it's weird as he said that to me
and honestly we get why Rob Marshall
casts her
that's a voice
Halle Bailey when she sang for us it was
so emotional she set the bar and no one
ever surpassed me next is everyone's
favorite sassy villain Ursula played by
funny gal Melissa McCarthy remember her
from our Gilmore Girls days and don't
forget Bridesmaids
is other key players are award-winning
actor Javier Bardem as Ariel's daddy
King Triton Hamilton star David Diggs as
Sebastian the crab actress and rapper
Aquafina as Scuttle a female diving bird
instead of a male seagull like the
original so that she can appear in
underwater scenes Jacob Tremblay as
flounder looking a little spooky but
still kinda cute and last but definitely
not least Jonah Howard King as Prince
Eric fun fact Harry Styles was actually
originally set to take on the prince but
dropped out as he wanted to focus on
darker roles but my friends we gotta get
out of here so let's see Haley do her
thing one more time cue the chills
I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
[Music]
I love you
so my land friends that's everything you
need to know before you go and see The
Little Mermaid in theaters May 26th
thanks for watching and be sure to rate
and review this film at
rottentomatoes.com